oh we're back look at that Michael
Teufel pointed at me hi there everybody
its Andrew it is the weekend I'm sitting
in for rich today Rich Eisen on the
appropriately named Rich Eisen show he
is back on Monday back from his European
vacation look who we have here five
seasons the NFL's second overall pick in
1998 the host now is a broadcaster Ryan
Leaf you're a broadcaster on pac-12 this
morning and on pac-12 XM Sirius channel
373 hello fellow broadcaster and and fs1
analyst is yeah it's a like Karma right
for how bad I treated the media when I
play it is that is kind of weird yeah
it's kind of come full circle so now
when I get the when I get the blowback
and the feedback I'm just like yeah
that's about right did you ever imagine
that you would be doing this well I went
to college for it so you know Washington
State University has the Murrell
communication school where a lot of
broadcasters come out I mean Keith
Jackson came from there so it was what
my my major was in when I was there but
when I left to go to the NFL early and
when I went back to finish my degree the
last place I wanted to be was in a
newsroom and I would have to do an
internship there right so I changed my
major to humanities and I didn't do it
if I would just you know you know you
know picked up my picked up my big boy
pants and went into the newsroom and
like took some accountability and got
the job I had been probably doing this
many many years ago and kind of been
able to put everything to the side
instead I just sat in this victim stands
for about you know 10 years because of
it do you like it I do but sports were
so toxic for me for so long especially
football that I stayed away from it as
much as possible but this is what my dad
and I did every morning you know he'd
wake me up to go to school and we sit
around the breakfast table we have our
breakfast in our cereal and we talk
sports you know we talk stats and my mom
would be laying in bed after a long
shift nursing that night she was a RN
nurse and she said she could always tell
what season it was by what my dad and I
were talking about the breakfast it I
say it's funny you say that because you
obviously weren't elite athlete right so
you come to this business from that
person with that perspective and with
that background I think for so many of
us speaking for myself at least that
story rings true for me because for
those of us that were never good enough
and tall enough for that matter we
wanted to do this and we
learn to do this by having those exact
same breakfast table conversations with
our dads and I think that I was humbled
in a way where I view myself as the same
as everybody else and sometimes when
we're placed on a pedestal as an athlete
for so long and maybe you don't have
that crash getting into the media
afterwards isn't necessarily where you
want to go because you know you you you
haven't had that kind of humbling where
you you feel the same I think that was
very very good transitionally for me to
be able to get into this business and
then treat everybody with respect and
the way I want to be treated Ryan Leaf
is with us the second overall picked in
98 now on Fox now on Sirius XM as well
and you did speaking of taking people
off I take some people off we're talking
about this during the break here by
saying you think the Browns should go
Josh Rosen number one which isn't a
controversial opinion but so I didn't
hear anybody talking about it this way
everybody's talking about Cleveland and
how what they all have and Dorsey being
there now and Wolf and the draft picks
and I just my opinion was if I had a if
I had the leverage of a Sam Donald or
Josh Rosen right now at the top of the
draft I want to empower them as a former
quarterback who ended up being a bust I
want to empower them and I'm not saying
it was a charge of all that was my fault
but Cleveland in my mind as an
organization if I were one of their
agents I'd be going to them going hey we
got to figure out a way not to where you
don't have to even now with John Dorsey
in alonzo highsmith and the move I think
I'm where Jarvis Landry seen a little
more hyperbolic just because I haven't
heard anybody come from that angle you
know I immediately went to like you know
Eli Manning shutting the Chargers to go
to the Giants and win two Super Bowls
John Elway doing it so what's happened
before there's a precedent there isn't
any I'm betting on futures in Cleveland
I'm betting that these new guys coming
in are gonna do something that the pass
guys who they thought were going to be
successful haven't been able to do
either so I'm almost like a scientific
analytical way of looking at it and
going if I were one of them when I want
to go to Buffalo who's on the uptick or
maybe Arizona something like that or
were either New York team Denver you
know either New York team yes so that is
my impression
and what it wasn't that was my take
wasn't necessarily it's not a referendum
on Cleveland the city
I think Cleveland City is amazing I
think it's the culture in the atmosphere
of the organization and hopefully that's
going to change but I was just throwing
another idea out there like hey I'm Sam
Darnell I'm going to my agent saying hey
let's figure out a way how we we don't
end up and clean and I think part of
that as well not putting words in your
mouth isn't necessarily as anti
Cleveland as some may take it but it's
also as you said empowering the athlete
it's not all about that now right so I
want cuz these teams will cut you
immediately right soon as soon as you've
given them your last drop of sweat in
their eyes they'll let you go they'll
cut you there's no issue with that
the idea that this young man who may be
the most talented player in the draft
has no choice in the matter where in
reality he actually has that but the way
we look at things professional sports
wise it's really archaic how it was done
in the 50s and gone on maybe some
analytics have changed but the way we
prepare and some of the things that that
that's still exist we just go with it
you know the lower the lowest-rated team
goes on 116 they draft first they need
the most improvement but the best player
in college you know but as a 21 year old
- you're not thinking that way you're
thinking like I can save that place I
can be the savior and if you can if you
can be the quarterback that leads
Cleveland out of it and media Hall of
Fame right he'll be the they'll rename
the town Darnall and you know that's
what's gonna happen if that happens if
it does happen talking to Ryan Leaf here
in the Rich Eisen show Andrew Siciliano
sitting in forget about the the thought
of Cleveland let's just go back to the
idea that you would take Josh Rosen over
Sam darn 'old over Josh Allen over Baker
Mayfield white well I think he's the
most fundamentally and technically sound
player in this draft ready to play right
now and isn't that like the the
prerequisite for being a quarterback in
this league the best passer
fundamentally tech surely I think he's a
great leader we've talked to many of his
teammates they back him up and what he's
done I think they're the red flags that
people have thrown out there is his lack
of want to they say because he has other
ambitions or as one one person put you
know character like where his values lie
I think it's kind of a lack of
leadership I think that's
people want to say that they couch it
with those other terms and it's not true
you know I got the luxury of being able
to sit with him about a month before he
declared and I got to see the way he
thought and he thinks outside the box he
wants to be the best possible
quarterback he can be he's willing to
work at it but he also sees something
different and he saw making that
decision whether to go to the NFL now or
next year was that to New York market
teams were gonna be drafting within the
first three picks and he thought to
himself I cannot pass up that
opportunity to be in a market like that
and that's thinking outside the box when
you look at an athlete who now is like
your mentors the way you look at it you
look at a LeBron right a man who's the
best at his business but also a
businessman a very good businessman you
can do both things you can be great at
your sport and still have a voice and
still be very good in in the business
acumen part of it right and that's the
example teams don't want to hear that
from a 21 year old teams don't wanna
throw for maybe a 30 year old or 28 year
old in free agency that's one thing
right but a 21 year old know they want
to hear want to hear it they want to
hear football football football football
and if that's not the case then they're
going to because there's a lot of spin
out there they can spin it anywhere they
want they could release some things to
some reporters or things like that that
get played out that way cuz every
interaction I've had with him or seen he
seems very self-aware and add the
advocate for his teammate that's what
I've seen with Josh Rosen yeah and he
can spin it I mean he could spin it as
as well as anybody and when he was here
he made the point to rich that obviously
people make a lot of his family
background he came from a good family
that certainly had money he lived in
Manhattan Beach and he made the point
that hey I don't necessarily need
football clearly but the fact that I
want to play football should tell you
about what drives me and should tell you
about my desire want to talk to you
about hold on one sec Baker Mayfield
some comments you made as well and
double back on some stuff you just said
there by yourself don't go anywhere this
is Ryan Leaf now with Fox in Sirius XM
Andrew and forage eyes and we're back in
60 seconds on the Rich Eisen show
it is the Rich Eisen show an audience on
FS RI major Siciliano riches back on
Monday hope you're looking at a great
Passover in Easter and Final Four
weekend Ryan Leaf now with I'm going
masters on some of the masters of the
week this is a first world problem this
is my first time in four years I'm not
going I've gone three consecutive years
it is killing me especially considering
Tiger is back yeah you have a good time
I am I'm really looking forward to it
this is the third year in row for me to
but this time I'm going with a bunch of
buddies cuz we're gonna just play a ton
of golf and go to the Wednesday practice
round which I've not done it here that's
amazing the par-3 I think it's the best
day to go we saw two years ago when with
my dad and brothers we watched we
watched three guys hit throwing ones on
the par three thing it's amazing yeah it
was it was it was amazing it is such a
cool place and I'm saying this and I am
and we are very fortunate to have been
to Augusta multiple times I'm not the
biggest golf fan but the moment I walked
in there like after 20 minutes you walk
around and you just say alright I get it
yeah like I I I get and I had the I was
fortunate enough to do that at Wimbledon
once a couple of years ago as well you
walk in you go
me too hi this is cool yeah this is this
is special and again we are fortunate
and these are first world problems that
if anyone can get to either of them it
is absolutely worth the bucket and it's
amazing for me because I mean if you
know anything about my story where I was
three-and-a-half years ago I'm traveling
on Sunday and April first in six years
ago I was arrested went to prison on
April 1st and it's six years later I'm
in six years sober I'm going to Augusta
with my friends I mean the gratitude
that I have around this because of the
perspective I have is amazing that's my
it's my sober birthday I get to spend it
with friends we're gonna play a ton of
golf that's awesome and just just take
everything and be as grateful about as
we can
you're gonna make the difficult turn
here back to football yeah you said the
word perspective and I think your
perspective here is key about Baker
Mayfield I hesitate to make the
comparison but you kind of went there
when you said the comparison with me and
I'm reading from a quote here is more
appropriate for Mayfield the highly
competitive border
arrogant angry individual the biggest
thing for me will be how he deals with
fate with failure you said that was your
downfall and you see that in him well I
don't I don't know if I see it at him I
see the same qualities what I do now is
it's a new exercise where I'll listen to
a lot of people do their press
conferences and I'll close my eyes and
if I hear a statement or hear some said
that sounds like 1998 version of Ryan
Leaf I tend to kind of throw a red flag
you've heard that with him I have I mean
some of the things that are said of
course but there is a borderline with
his quarterbacks right of arrogant to
confident there's that set sharp edge
right there and you want you want one of
those but it can fall over the other
side the arrogant side of when you start
to fail when the first game happens
where you perform poorly the media
zhonya the towns anya how you react to
it it wasn't that I played poorly in San
Diego is how I dealt with it is what
went down fall was I just hadn't failed
like that in college or in high school
and finally when I did fail on a on a
high level was at the very top level
where everybody was watching and I how I
dealt with it was what's the part was
where the problem was and that's what my
biggest fear is with him
he's had so much success he's has this
kind of borderline angry you know chip
on your shoulder what happens when the
media starts going after you or the town
or you and you don't have your good play
to cover that up right a lot of guys who
may have red flags for behavior problems
and are super talented and play well
sometimes that gets overlooked and that
of course happened to me early on in my
life I behaved any way I wanted to but I
was still placed on this pedestal and I
can make up for it on a Friday night a
Saturday morning or ultimately a Sunday
afternoon and when that didn't happen
anymore you have to answer for those
things and there's accountability that
needs to take place I don't necessarily
know when things get bad if he's that
guy your self-awareness is refreshing
here and I know that you said just there
it's not the Chargers it's me but go
back to to Wazzu did no one prepare you
or tell you Ryan you can't deal with the
media this way you can't lash out
against others this way I you know it
you're such that you're such a small
fish tank there right I mean it was one
beat reporter really until we beat wash
to go to the Rose Bowl in Sports
Illustrated showed up and then there was
a joke that was written in the article
you know what was the difference between
God and Ryan Leaf and the punchline is
that God doesn't think he's Ryan Leaf
that's how it and at the time I probably
thought that right and that's that's
that's sickening to think that way but
that was when the first thing started to
kind of come out that that I had a huge
chip on my shoulder that I thought I was
much more important than anybody else
because of what I did it just didn't get
recognized there because it was in such
a small market in Washington State
doesn't especially back in 20 years ago
you know wasn't playing for a Rose Bowl
hell they hadn't done it since 1931
so no one really was coach Price tried
to help me along with that you know but
I just I'd like to say I'd listened when
I turned pro and lease timer signed me
as an agent he introduced me to all his
clients Troy Aikman Steve Young Drew
Bledsoe all these guys Ryan here their
numbers reach out to them ask them
questions I always when I my first game
was against Steve Young in the San
Francisco 49ers and we beat him and I
remember talking to him after the game
still not feeling like their peer right
at like still like in awe that this was
Steve Young and I could not show any
weakness to him like hey I'm really
struggling with this how did you deal
with this that's why I implore these
young athletes to do that find somebody
who's been through what you've been
through and ask them how they did it
because they've done it the right way
and that's a big part of what I do now I
travel a lot to college campuses talk to
University of Alabama Georgia things
like that and I tell the guys just
because you're a great athlete doesn't
make you a good person let's build that
foundation first and usually great
things happen from there and that's kind
of where I've taken it from my
experience you use the B word earlier
yeah you said bust how long did it take
you to be able to say that well I mean I
think it's I think the only people that
say it are people in news when I talk to
my peers and guys I played with or
people who were in the league they don't
they don't look at me that way or call
me that because they know how hard it is
to get to where we got to it's the top
1% of the top 1% but it's a stigma that
exists right if you don't succeed that
were
translates to who you are defines who
you are and for the longest time I
bought into it I thought you know I
didn't meet those expectations my
expectations were very high and I didn't
meet him and that's who I was but I'm
Ryan and that took a long time that took
a lot of self work being okay with what
my identity was you know for the longest
I was Ryan the football player and then
Ryan the failed football player and Ryan
the drug addict then Ryan the felon
which none of of matters anymore I'm
just I'm just Ryan I'm I'm a dad now you
know I'm a fiancee I'm a flawed human
being just like you trying to be better
I am trying and I don't know that I
could sit here your store is much
different than mine but most people
don't have that self-awareness they
can't and they certainly can't do it
publicly well I think my all my failures
or all my the dumpster fire of my life
for a while was so public and it
probably saved my life because really
there's so many people out there that
struggle with what I struggle with
mental health and substance abuse that
are in this shadow are in the shadows
and never have a spotlight shone on them
every time I messed up everybody knew
about it was it the humiliation factor
or the fact that others were willing to
reach out and try to help you because
they did see it
I wouldn't necessarily the humiliation
part of it it was the consequences I
think I I wasn't a good criminal right I
got busted I got sent to jail I just was
talking to one of your producers before
him and I liked the idea that you were
hosting today because while I was in
prison I had the NFL red zone and got to
see your smiling face every Sunday
afternoon the funky low so here we are
full circle
that's pretty amazing yeah I can't
imagine what it's like to go through
that and then come through and this is
me saying you don't have to as well as
you have well it's not I still mess up
all the time
of course you know I'm the human yeah
that's and that was the difference right
I I thought when I messed up no one
could see it right that we had to put on
this persona in the in the perception of
others is so important what other people
think of me is so important when in
reality what other people think of me is
none of my business really the people
that who I've asked to hold me
accountable that's who I care about when
they think of me
because a lot of times I'll still miss
up and those people that who hold me
accountable to show me that mirror
because they'll go Ryan that's old
behavior and when I get to do stuff like
this again or now I become a voice for
something that ego gets involved again
so I need those people around me to rein
me in and I've asked them to do that
right and understand that when I get an
opportunity to do this and sit in front
of you and tell you my story or talk
about this it's about your viewer or
your listener who may be struggling and
going through the same thing I did or
know somebody who's going through the
same same thing I did and can't ask for
help can reach out and understand it's a
strength to do that and not a
vulnerability or a weakness sadly I only
have about 30 seconds left that's pretty
much the message though you tell these
college kids right yeah
I really just walk in and tell my story
I don't go in and tell them what to do
or what not to do because when I was 21
if somebody tried to tell me what to do
I usually kind of flip them the bird and
walked off and said I'm doing that stuff
right and so I just tried to tell my
story and it's it is what it is and the
cool thing about it is is once you are
truthful about it
you know you don't have to think about
all the lies you told or what stories
you went down or what what trails you
were down it's just it's just it's what
it is it's Who I am
you know take it or leave it we'll take
it thank you
Ryan Ryan leaf everybody from FS our Fox
Sports one
I said FS our Fox Sports one that's
that's my old radio days back here and
SiriusXM pac-12 of the morning dude it's
a pleasure to have you in it's great to
hear your stories because people need to
hear them and hopefully people can learn
for them as well and take something from
them because I know it's important to
you to be able to impress upon people
how you did it and that that they can
learn something from that so yeah I
appreciate that thanks for coming in man
thank you sir it's Ryan Leaf everybody
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience